now ed miliband leads the charge on
getting to net zero for the labour party
but it does feel like climate change may
be slipping down the priority list as
the cost of living crisis really starts
to bite so are people in pain from
storing energy costs is going green
still a vote winner for the party and
what would it do to help those
struggling to get by well let's talk now
to labour's shadow climate change
secretary ed miliband thank you very
much for being uh with us uh you want to
put down this amendment to the queen's
speech on a windfall tax just explain
the thinking behind it
frankly we face a social emergency in
this country sophie
seven million people we know are
skipping meals because they can't afford
their bills energy bills are rocketing
upwards
and at the same time as a direct result
of that we've got oil and gas companies
making billions of pounds literally
record profits
of course the right thing to do is to
levy a windfall tax on those oil and gas
companies so we can provide proper help
to families 200 pounds across the board
cutting bills for all families 600
pounds for 9 million families who are
facing the biggest struggles and that is
absolutely essential i will say to you i
think it is frankly obscene that the
government is refusing to do this i mean
i i listened to your quasi-quieting
interview i'm not interested in their
internal machinations about this because
every day that goes by when they refuse
to do the right thing is another day
when millions of people in this country
have sleepless nights about how they're
going to afford their bills my message
to the chancellor is this you're going
to do a windfall tax i believe he is
going to do a windfall tax because
frankly it's an unanswerable case get on
with it and do it and bring real help to
families
um at the same time i just wonder um
obviously you're someone who is pushing
the climate changer agenda something
that many of our viewers will be very
concerned about as well but at a time
when bills are going up a lot of these
measures heat pumps for example costing
10 000 pounds a lot of people will be
thinking look
i love the idea of going green but right
now i simply can't afford it and what
would you say to those people
well here's the thing sophie because
this is what's changed you see the
answer to the climate crisis we face is
also the answer to the cost of living
crisis we face labor's got a plan to
insulate 19 million homes over the next
10 years 2 million in the coming year
that would cut bills cut carbon
emissions
and create jobs if you take the green
energy sprint which we need and the
government is not doing onshore wind
solar are now our cheapest forms of
power we should be driving ahead with
those things we should be getting rid of
ridiculous planning rules in england
which stop onshore win that would cut
carbon emissions and cut bills for
consumers so the old debate was shall we
go green it'll be more expensive
actually the new reality is going green
is now the cheaper option and i'm afraid
the government's half-hearted approach
to these climate issues is not just bad
for the climate and it is terrible for
the climber it's also bad when it comes
to affordability and the cost of living
crisis as well as energy security
because we can cut our gas imports too
if actually we go on this green spring
at the same time though labour's green
new deal that would cost 28 billion
pounds every year i mean that's one
percent of uk gdp and to put that in
context you know the famous windfall tax
that you talk about in every a labor
politician on the show talks about that
would raise about 2 billion pounds at
best so you would need 14 windfall taxes
to pay for one year of the green new
deal i mean is this really
realistic no i'm very oh let me be very
let me very very clear about this we
think sophie that it is right to borrow
to invest that 28 billion pounds and let
me explain why
because the biggest challenge and the
big the most improved thing we could do
is fail to invest in tackling the
climate crisis because we will store up
massive costs for the future don't take
my word for it the office of budget
responsibility produce an excellent
report and you know i'm a bit nerdy so
i've kind of looked at their report in
detail that shows if we delay by a
decade if we delay climate action by a
decade we double the cost of going green
let me give you a very concrete example
on this just just to show you what it
means
because the government got rid of a zero
carbon home standard which would have
meant that all new homes would have been
built zero carbon we've built a million
homes since then we're going to have to
insulate retrofit those homes that's
going to cost us more money so it's
another example of why the prudent
choice the sensible economic choice the
sensible fiscal choice as well as the
ethical choice is to invest in in
tackling the climate emergency and
there's a huge potential of jobs in this
country one of which just made this
point one of one of the problems i have
with government is that they have no
plan for growth if we invest that money
in the automotive sector in electric
cars so we can get ahead in that in
steel so it can be transformed in new
industries like hydrogen it can create
good jobs at good wages the biggest
challenge we face the biggest long-term
economic challenge we face
if you're being honest with people
though wouldn't you spend a little bit
less time talking about the windfall tax
that raises two billion a year and spend
a bit more time being upfront about how
the fact like as you have just been that
labor would effectively be borrowing
billions and billions more pounds every
year to pay for this 28 billion
a year green new deal i'm being i'm
being i'm being extremely open and i'm
very happy to talk about both but let me
make this point to you
the reason why this matters is we have a
short-term plan and a long-term plan and
the short-term plan is really important
i do want to underline this point sophia
i was in assistance advice
office in my constituency on friday
meeting a couple and a single person who
are facing this cost of living christ
and let me just underline this this
point to you
these were people this was one set of
people who are homeowners and who are
deeply worried about how they'd afford
to pay their bills and another lady who
was renting our house on universal
credit incredibly worried
frankly just no hope of paying her
direct debit
this you know i know that we often talk
about emergencies and difficulties and
so on in my 30 years or so that i've
been involved in politics i have never
known a cost of living crunch like this
we're set for the biggest fallen living
standards for 45 years in our country so
i i make no apologies for talking and
demanding demanding the government act
on the windfall tax because it is quite
wrong that they are not doing so
how concerned are you about the impact
the war in ukraine could have on energy
bills in the future
i i am concerned about it and and you
know
what this illustrates is that
if we are subject to fossil fuels if we
are reliant on fossil fuels then we are
basically at the mercy of global events
and there's a real lesson here because
this is a fossil fuel crisis
and the best way for us to have energy
security and energy security is
incredibly important is frankly to get
off fossil fuels because the thing about
onshore wind offshore wind nuclear power
solar energy all of those things is they
are home-grown sources of power which
aren't reliant on what is happening
globally what is happening around the
world and so that's why it's so
important that we that we um
that we go on this green energy sprint
okay um now just talking about ukraine
um you know the atrocities that vladimir
putin's committed in ukraine were in
many ways foreshadowed uh by what russia
did in syria you know it's part of the
same playbook mario poll seemingly like
another aleppo the general known as the
butcher of syria now leading the war
effort in ukraine
do you regret voting against military
action in syria back in 2013
uh no no i don't uh sophie look what i
was presented with when it came to what
was happening uh in syria
was a proposition
where we would not have been getting rid
of all the chemical weapons but this was
about the chemical weapons attack
that president assad had made we would
not be getting rid of all his chemical
weapons and there was no proper plan for
how we would be using british troops and
where this where our intervention would
go and we made a vow after iraq which
was that if we committed british troops
we would do so clear about our
objectives with a clear sense of a plan
and a clear sense that that plan would
be successful and our argument to david
cameron was
set out a clear plan how this is going
to work and what is going to mean and
those who say well it would have changed
the course of the war president trump
did actually bomb president assad in
relation to a chemical weapons attack a
few years later and it did not change
the course of the war so so of course
what has happened in syria is an
appalling tragedy but the idea that us
getting involved in another war in the
middle east would have stopped it
happening i just don't buy i'm afraid i
understand about your concerns about not
having a proper strategy um at the time
but was it also about sending a message
to people around the world that if you
commit war crimes and the west will
act and by not doing anything then you
also sent a message to people like putin
that the west wouldn't necessarily act
you know i remember in the election
campaign when you were a leader that
sort of famous moment when you spoke to
jeremy paxman you said hell yes i'm
tough enough talking about refusing to
back the airstrikes in syria that barack
obama wanted you said standing up to the
leader of the free world shows a certain
toughness i would say
do you think the real toughness comes
from standing up to leaders of the
unfree world
i just want to say you said at the
beginning of that question should we not
have engaged in military action in order
to send a message
i think we should learn some lessons
from our past on this
because
when terrible things happen around the
world yes we have a responsibility uh to
act in concert with our allies and we
are acting in relation to ukraine and
with the toughest economic sanctions
providing defensive equipment rightly to
the ukrainian regime against the
appalling acts of putin
but
when we commit british troops we don't
just do so to send a message we are
putting the young men and women of our
country in harm's way
and i think that leaders have a deep
responsibility to know that they are
doing so on the basis that we have a
chance of it succeeding we have a clear
plan
and we know where where this where the
intervention is going to go so and you
know in relation to libya i supported
david cameron in relation to
intervention uh in libya because i
thought there was a plan in relation to
the kind of humanitarian emergency that
there was there but i took my
responsibility
incredibly seriously as somebody who
wanted to be the prime minister of the
country that if i was going to commit
british troops it was on the right basis
in the right way
and with a clear chance of success
okay um now moving on to a few other
issues in the news recently sadiq khan
the mayor of london has set up a
commission to look into the potential
legalization of cannabis
would you like to see cannabis legalized
that isn't labour's position no
uh what what what we've said and look we
welcome sadiq looking at these issues
because this debate uh carry carries on
and should carry on he's looking at a
whole range of issues under i think it's
lord faulkner a distinguished person
very wise person on these issues uh to
look at issues of treatment and
education
and the wider issues that you mentioned
what's your name labor isn't
convinced well look you know i've said
in the past that there's something this
is something that needs to be looked at
you i think you probably uh uh know that
but labour's shadow cabinet position
which is a position i support as a
member of the shadow cabinet is to say
that we're not yet convinced of the case
uh for moving on decriminalization but
obviously we'll look at what lord
faulkner's commission has to say
okay and now we had the local elections
two weeks ago and i think it is fair to
say of course that kirsten made progress
compared to the jeremy corbyn
position
would you say he's now stuck in uh ed
miliband territory
i'm not i don't i don't think you mean
that as a compliment sophie so maybe i
should say no um look i think what um i
think what keir is doing is that we had
a terrible defeat in 2019
he has done a remarkable job i think in
bringing the party back from the brink
from what happened in 2019 putting us
back on the pitch let me tell you what i
detected as i went around the country in
the local elections
i think there is a big mood for change
in this country not just the cost of
living crisis this goes back much
further to brexit to the financial
crisis people feel the country's not
working for them now i think people are
increasingly convinced that the tories
aren't going to deliver and i have to
say listening to that quasi-quieting
interview it's no wonder people think
the tories can't deliver our job is to
show that we can bring that change and
that is a work in progress of course it
is we've got really important ideas like
the windfall tax like the climate
investment pledge and what you're going
to see and what i know kira is
determined to do is to show that burning
passion and that set of proposals to
change our country to bring the change
that i think people are crying out for
in this country you know remember after
the pandemic or during the pandemic
sophie we said we would build back
better all of us across politics
actually at the moment we're set to
build back far worse under this
government so we've got to show that we
can bring the change we need and i'm
convinced we can
okay thank you for taking that with uh
customary good humor it's appreciated uh
just finally before i let you go and
it's fair to say i think that his time
was going through one of the more
difficult
periods of his leadership
have you offered him any advice on it
i think all periods for um at the leader
of the opposition are challenging at
least in my experience sophie as you
know you were with me in the campaign of
2015. he doesn't need my advice you know
i think the thing about gear is that the
more people get to know him the more
they like what they see he's somebody of
great decency great integrity somebody
who cares deeply about this country what
what what drives kiev stammer in my view
what drives him is this country doesn't
work for millions of people across our
land this economy doesn't work for
millions of people across our country
and actually what his burning passion is
to change that economy to deliver good
jobs at decent wages to restore our
public services and to tackle the
climate crisis and create those good
jobs i was talking about and you know
the whole of the labour party is united
behind him in that mission
okay thank you uh very much uh indeed ed
miliband there thank you thank you